en este vídeo vamos a ver un ejemplo de
ecuación diferencial de segundo orden
con coeficientes constantes pero que
supone no lo característico tenga raíces
repetidas este es el caso nuevo que
estábamos estudiando bien pues voy a
tomar la ecuación yeví prima menos 10
prima más punto 25 la función normal sin
ninguna derivada y esto le voy a igualar
a cero debido a que mi función es
homogéneo y además le voy a dar las
condiciones iniciales a este problema
que vamos a resolver las cuales van a
ser ya de cero es igual a dos y de prima
de cero le voy a poner que es un tercio
recuerda del que ustedes se pueden poner
cualquier valor a las condiciones
iniciales recuerden también que en todos
los vídeos que hemos visto en todos lo
primero que hacíamos era encontrar la
ecuación característica que estaba
asociada en este caso me va a quedar que
la ecuación característica es r cuadrada
menos ere más punto 25 a secas y esto
iguala vamos a cero pero si esta
igualdad a cero esta ecuación es una
ecuación de segundo grado y cómo se
resuelven las ecuaciones de segundo
grado pues con la fórmula general de
ecuación
de segundo grado así que de una vez
utilicemos la me queda r es igual a
menos b pero menos por menos 1 me va a
quedar más 1 más menos la raíz cuadrada
de menos 1 al cuadrado que es 1 ya esto
yo lo tenía que restar cuatro veces a
que vale 1 x sé que vale punto 25 04 por
punto 25 es lo mismo que 4 por un cuarto
que es 1 y es aquí donde nos damos
cuenta de que solamente vamos a tener
una raíz porque porque uno menos uno va
a ser cero y si yo saco la raíz a cero
pues es cero y si a uno le sumó más
menos cero pues solamente va a ser uno
perfecto y ahora sí todo lo divido entre
dos a pero a vale uno pues va a ser dos
por uno dos bien como ya vimos uno menos
10 y la raíz de 0 0 entonces solamente
voy a tener una raíz en este caso mi
raíz va a ser un medio
ahora utilicemos lo que vimos en el
vídeo pasado en el vídeo pasado nosotros
vimos cómo podíamos resolver este tipo
de problemas con una raíz y si hacemos
un poco de memoria y recordamos que
igual hace por un medio de x esto no era
la solución general de hecho esta
solución estaba incompleta entonces lo
que nosotros hacíamos era hacer una
nueva función que le llamábamos ye igual
a vd x que multiplicaba elevado a la un
medio de x ha elevado a mi primer raíz
por equis y si nosotros recordamos todo
lo que vimos la vez pasada pues
derivamos esta función dos veces
sustituimos y llegábamos a kebede x
tenía la forma de 1 + x x c 2 bien
entonces utilizando esto voy a sustituir
para obtener mi solución general la cual
tenía la forma se uno por el ala un
medio de x y esto le sumamos de 2 por x
por el ala un medio
x olvide la equis aquí bien y nosotros
nos damos cuenta en este momento que ese
a un medio de x c 2 x al a un medio de x
es la forma rápida de resolver todo el
procedimiento que hicimos la vez pasada
si ustedes se quieren aprender solamente
la formulita para algún examen o algún
ejercicio rápido lo pueden realizar bien
pero lo que sí quiero que noten también
es que la solución tenía la forma de un
medio de x x una constante y después era
a la un medio de x otra vez pero
multiplicamos por x y por otra constante
y si ya determinamos la solución general
ahora lo que necesitamos es saber las
dos constantes vamos a determinar las
constantes con las condiciones iniciales
como lo hemos hecho siempre para eso
necesitamos la primera derivada que
quien va a ser pues en algún medio de x
baja en un medio y me queda un medio por
c 1 por algún medio de x y si yo quiero
derivar ahora c 2 x un medio de x pues
es una multiplicación de funciones así
que primero voy a derivar a x qué es
y me va a quedarse 2 x
a un medio de equis y después voy a
derivar ella de un medio de x que es un
medio lo multiplicó por equis porque la
tengo que dejar tal cual y me va a
quedar multiplicada por un medio de x
perfecto pero ahora lo que voy a hacer
es reducir la primera derivada para que
nos quede de una manera más manejable y
la podemos utilizar usando las
condiciones iniciales que me va a quedar
fíjense que en algún medio de x aparece
tanto aquí como acá y aquí lo multiplica
por 2 y aquí por un medio de ese 1
entonces voy a factorizar el y un medio
de x iba a multiplicar aquí
bueno pues multiplicada uno entre dos un
medio por segundo es segundo entre dos
más dos perfecto y el otro sumando pues
me va a quedar ese dos por un medio que
es c 2 entre 2 por x por el ala un medio
de x perfecto y así va a ser mucho más
fácil tratarla cuando nosotros pongamos
las condiciones iniciales
creo que voy a ahorrar un poco de pluma
y ahorrar un poco de espacio y voy a
borrar algo aquí para no reescribir otra
vez todo lo que tengo abajo entonces voy
a borrar esto de aquí hasta aquí y voy a
borrar estar acá y los espacios estos
que me quedan un poco sucio bien
recuerdan que era procedimiento de todo
lo que ya hemos hecho y además era algo
de lo que nosotros no deberíamos hacer
cuando tenemos raíces repetidas bien si
ya tengo en mi función original y ya
tengo mi primera derivada pues es muy
lógico pensar en usar las condiciones
iniciales entonces usemos las
condiciones iniciales yo sé que tiene
cero es igual a 2 entonces dicho de otra
manera 2 es igual a 1 por el acero pero
ea la cero pues es 1 entonces se uno por
uno me queda hace 1
y si yo pongo 0 en x en el segundo
sumando dese cuenta que algo va a pasar
si x vale 0 en el segundo sumando pues
todo se va porque se dos por cero por
cero pues es cero
entonces ya tengo por fin mi primer
condición inicial dado que ya tengo
ahora hace uno ahora lo que se me ocurre
es sustituir ese uno en mi primera
derivada así va a ser mucho más fácil yo
pude obtener hace dos de mi primera
derivada de prima ya que voy a sustituir
hace uno me va a quedar de esta
siguiente manera se 1 entre 2 es lo
mismo que 2 entre 2 pero 2 entre 2 es 1
entonces me va a quedar 2 entre 2 que es
uno más de dos o sea uno más de dos bien
lo voy a escribir aquí y esto estaba x
a un medio de x muy bien y ahora veamos
qué es lo que tenemos que hacer con el
segundo sumando el segundo sumando pues
no tiene ese uno entonces lo ponemos tal
cual c 2 entre 2 por x por el ala un
medio de x aquí me falta un x perfecto
ahora hay que utilizar la segunda
condición inicial que quiere decir que
prima de 0 es un tercio es decir cada
vez que yo vea a x voy a poner 0
entonces me va a quedar un tercio es
igual a 1 más de 2 más y si yo pongo 0
en x pues todo esto se va entonces ya no
es en serio escribirlo me queda simple y
sencillamente que un tercio es igual a
12 o dicho de otra manera se 2 es igual
a menos dos tercios pasivo el uno del
otro lado y un tercio menos uno pues son
menos dos tercios perfecto entonces esto
me da pie a poder escribir ya mi
solución de mi ecuación diferencial con
una solución completamente particular
pues ya tengo tanto hace uno como hace
dos que me va a quedar mi respuesta va a
ser igual a 2 por un medio de x
solamente estoy sustituyendo en mi
solución particular y a esto lo tengo
que restar dos tercios de x por el ala
un medio de x lo único que hice fue
sustituir a c1 y c2 en mi solución
general para así obtener la solución
particular
y es así como hemos terminado pero
quiero que se den cuenta antes de
finalizar este vídeo que si ustedes
quieren hacer una forma rápida de
encontrar la solución de este tipo de
ecuaciones diferenciales de segundo
orden pues es muy fácil porque lo que
tenemos que hacer es fijarnos en la
ecuación diferencial en la ecuación
característica después encontrar una
solución general y esta solución general
derivar la y después utilizar las
condiciones iniciales y ya con eso
nosotros tenemos la solución particular
de lo que buscábamos en el siguiente
vídeo analizaremos las ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden que no
son homogéneas nos vamos a divertir
bastante así que pues no se lo pierdan